oby I got this book I forget out so much
in time below the belt I was on a show
with Jim Norton right yeah and they
brought in this FBI forensic guy he's
the guy that showed mine hunters on
Netflix
please interview Charles Manson Jeffrey
Dahmer he's he's the main guy do you
know what his name is Richard Walter
what was Johnny Douglas Johnny Douglas
okay
John Douglas they bring him in whenever
there's an unsolved serial killer case
or a murder case they bring him in
because he always sees outside the bomb
yes and solves it
he was fascinating I bet fascinating
that he said when he was interviewing
Charles Manson so a control thing so it
was him and another guy Charles has to
be higher than you so when he was just
like spewing and and ranting to his
followers he's always on a chair because
you know he was 5 - so yeah it was a
tiny so he said went to interview
Charles Manson as soon as Charles walks
in he grabbed a chair and stood on top
of it Chuck and he goes I didn't
acknowledge it but I knew what he's
trying to do but you give him that
control because you get more out of him
so he was we had to look up that Charles
and he would only talk to us that way
it's fat what he was talking about these
in a psychology behind there's a serial
killer who's there doing his new book
his books out it is it's so hot power
right power and like the way people are
[ __ ] in it what a job there he is
Johnny does what a job what a job he was
saying that you know we're like oh it's
just a mental illness he's like that
doesn't fly it's not mental illness he
goes some of these serial killers and
some of these murders that you meet have
the highest IQ the most normal people
you meet and there's certain reasons why
they do it it's not a mental illness
they just get off on the power right
it's a Power Move it's a sexual they got
a sexual pleasure off of being like like
that they're saying the guy who me like
I was setting up setting fires yeah and
then would watch him yeah they said he
would set fires and the power that that
he had control that the fire trucks
would come and all those people and
resources he'd sit there and jack off
watch the fireman put the fire there's a
sexual power that's right that's what
Richard I know where does that I think
it was Richard Walter said they were
finding women by the riverbank killed
and he said he goes plant a car you'll
find him masturbating in his car
and then that's exactly what he was
doing they would find the guy who would
pull up in masturbate and think about
what he had done that kind of [ __ ] this
of my friends a criminal lawyer he had
to defend this kid he would kept defend
this kid who he would start a fire and
then dress up like a fireman and driving
around the fire yeah yeah he got off on
it
it's very strange this guy was saying
too for this there's this one murder
with a seven year old girl and they
found semen on her leg and that she's
been you know raped and murdered seven
year old and the cops get a horrible the
cops came in with this pedophile rape
the case solved done and he's like
you're off man that's it that's not
what's going on here so he sat down and
talked to him and it was it was a power
thing it was it wouldn't matter if it's
a seven year old or a 33 year or 30 38
year old but he just wanted power over
this person so this person showed up at
the wrong time she was Girl Scout
cookies murdered her but the reason why
she had semen on her legs is because he
was so excited the thought they had this
power yeah he you ejaculate it yeah
yeah but they're like oh that's easy
pedophile and he's like no it's not you
guys are you're so on yeah he has no
history of that if the pedophile he
would have coerced her and set her up
and kind of groomed her this isn't a
pedophile case and he would have done it
next door he's murder murders murder
scenes murders have their own
fingerprint I asked this guy to I go how
can you sleep at night man like you
stole me so you met him I was on the
show oh [ __ ] I thought it was a book
okay so he gave me his book after we had
him I'm gonna read it it was just what
he said when you said that he was saying
that night he's like sometimes he's he
has three kids yeah say yes sometimes
it's heavy to take home and gives will
eventually get used to it because he's
seen the worst of the worst the worst of
the worst
and I [ __ ] up and asked the worst
thing he ever said there is John Douglas
you [ __ ] him asked him ah dark Shipman
yeah super doctor and he was saying how
like the when these murders and
circulars not really steal kill even the
murders are up for parole the parole
board's like are you better did you go
through president everything all good
he's like you guys are doing it wrong of
course he's a model citizen inside
prison because there's a system and he
follows each thing and then moves on you
put him in the real world he's not
holding his hand he's gonna [ __ ] up
again that's and he knows how to
manipulate you guys I don't think you
should never be that's he goes you can't
manipulate me so he he interviews them
too they sent him when they're up for
parole and man he's good it was so
fascinating dude Wow
I think he's written like four books his
newest ones really fascinating the thing
those things [ __ ] me up though yeah I
got through almost a quarter of it on
the plane and it's so dark it's so dark
it's such a bummer and you know what's
interesting I even occurred to me when
they go oh the the parents need closure
yeah any closure he goes there's no such
thing as closure now so in he said what
else the parents want that in this
seven-year-old who was murdered the mom
wanted the details the exact details
what happened to his daughter which he
knew of yeah and he was they want the
details he's not for closure
cuz they're gonna have to carry this for
the rest of their life we want to know
it's like there she saw you want to know
exactly what she was she said yeah I can
I have a sin so have my seven-year-old
said that oh I don't know anything I
don't know well there's nothing worse
heavy
there's nothing worse heavy but biggest
he said the one thing that did help the
mom is he's like she fought say that
right now she fought yeah it was nasty
man makes you sad yeah it makes you sad
you make sure she's also makes you helps
you realize how [ __ ] up people are cuz
you somehow this guy's not that how he's
not mentally insane cuz everything was
everything she got played yeah here's
the other thing that he knew he couldn't
let him out of prison because he goes
were you surprised by my fingers I was
surprised how hard is to choke a person
at death he was I choked her choked
unconscious left her thought she was
dead went downstairs to get a bag to
prayer I came back she was torch in he's
like what the [ __ ]
so grabbed her by the feet all right yep
she's dirty shipment
yeah we're not startled by the Oh dirty
but he but he was basically saying how
this guy's been in surgery for 30 years
and he's like nothing's gonna help these
people thats gonna help okay syrupy if
you kill a kid or you you rape you're
going away forever you should but then
you just kill you because you like them
Tokyo's the show that he's like you so
much higher than everybody's and they're
so aware of what you're trying to
get out of them so you sent him this
therapist this parolee whatever he ought
to tell you to get out of course so you
guys aren't helping him like he's
uncurable it's in him that's what he
wants to do
I didn't you kill him put him down like
a sick dog they were there saying this
this is and this isn't a kid one so it's
not as bad but there was this guy right
and he had he had real bad anger issues
and he bought this
he always had bad anger issues and he
killed a guy when he's like 17 in
traffic whatever so he did like 20 years
got out what got out was out for like a
month or so and then what do you think
he's good not this guy the parolees like
he's good
he's checked all the boxes he's
reincarnate he's fine he's white better
we fix him a therapy he's good to go
he's a young move gets out a month later
he goes he finally stays money is that
he loved motorcycles goes into
motorcycle shop there's six guys there
and he gets on the bike and he's like
trying to start it he wasn't familiar
with it the guys in the shop start
making fun of them I got that [ __ ] you
doing you gonna ride that thing blah
blah and the guys like do I'm here to
buy a bike they start making foam you
can't buy get the [ __ ] out the bike you
got buy this bike and he had cash in his
pocket to buy bike he's always wanted
guys keep making fun of me alright cool
man
[ __ ] it [ __ ] your bike alright that's
cool leaves wait a year
here goes back in there's no same six
people murders all six the cops come and
go what the [ __ ] man this is a robbery
they bring in homeboy here goes say no
robbery no this is a path this is this
is all calculate this is someone who was
very upset and something happen they
found the guy he goes yeah man we're
here to buy a bike and they he was
liking they started making fun of me so
he waited a year
just let it stew until they can figure
out was him came back huh that's the
scariest kind of guy and just kind of
guys I'll get you but that's what he's
saying so if you would have interviewed
the guy then with the parole board he
would pass all the tests and be fine and
the bike I'll let him go
but there's these people have these
traits inside and where he might not
kill right when he gets out of prison
right but it could be five years that's
five years that's right that's right the
murder room is another book about this
guy who was like that who could just
solve the craziest [ __ ] the crate you
look at a murder scene and be like this
is a muscular guy who didn't have sex
with her after she was dead you know
what it is it's always the mom
relationships it's always the
relationships with the mom Oh dad's
really always moms Wow yeah he's like
he's always the mother son really
shipped that but usually cousin [ __ ]
up if they're overbearing yeah they say
they say wife beaters men who hit women
like a [ __ ] Willy apparently a lot of
times there are men whose mothers left
or had very troubled relationships and
what people listen the first time okay
well there is that there is that no no
no but but but so so that they can't
control a woman so as soon as they start
dating girl they'll ask for it they'll
tell like it'll start with little things
like where are you what's your number
then then dress me and give me your
phone I want your phone although I'm and
they just start controlling you that way
he was saying I asked him the toughest
case he's ever had to solve and he said
there's the strangle strangle torture
bang kill bind now fine torture kill be
flying at the BTK
so the ETA killer he saw that so check
the sign torture so the bind torch goes
28-year career of murdering people
serial killer yeah but 12 family took
six years off yeah so did their fallen
tendencies six years goes by like what
the [ __ ] dude I where did that he must
have died who got picked up for prison
but then the murder start happening
again he was a family man
yeah worked at a church yep working at
her family and you know why stopped his
wife because he used to like do sadistic
stuff so he liked to get choked and
jackoff yeah but his family had no idea
his wife walked in him in a suit choked
himself jacking off and she went what
the religious she went what the [ __ ] are
you doing and he thought because
everyone's looking for this killer and
he you know he had she even was like
Manny sounds like the describe means
like I know it's ridiculous right but he
thought man if I get caught again she's
gonna put two and two together so he
stopped doing it for six years or some
[ __ ] like that and then was like oh I'm
good to go start doing it again after
six years Wow crazy right cuz they were
like he was the only one where it didn't
make sense it never looking in there
with his daughter look at him just Ted
just a guy with his that with it he did
awful things to Fant would kill the
whole family choke mine yeah torture
kill yeah nice guy that was his slogan
look at this [ __ ] creep what a piece
of it off this is creepy use oh look he
fishes to Jin oh wow that's great
click on that what is that drawing up
chin click on it this one yes the most
disturbing images of what created oh so
here just like that ban and women a
woman's mask nice guy keep scrolling
down it's so weird
whoa he would bury people alive I think
that's just his art work or like Tahoe
yeah yeah it looks like art yeah just
messed up art mmm yeah what a terrible
person let me kill kids the whole
family's and torture yeah it's a good
guy I mean you know I don't know I don't
know man I don't know what goes on in
this world oh you know what else it and
we'll move on after murder and death
after yep shout out to murder in death
um yeah just about JonBenet they put on
a jonbenét case yeah and he goes I goes
the parents right he goes that drives me
nuts he goes he goes no he was the
boulder police department [ __ ] it up
so bad with outsiders like you gonna ask
me X which ever seen murder
that ain't the parents it's night he was
slamming clothes he was that girl was
tortured she was it was not quick the
way she was tortured is not a family
member you'd have to know what you're
doing you have to have time and then I
go what about the brother goes you think
an eight-year-old did that I felt so
stupid oh my god
no I mean like was he a I just went was
he eight now that wasn't the brightest
not a chance
here's the way the method that they used
to kill and it was that was a passion
crime they wanted something out of it he
was in it was I can guarantee it was not
the parents he was guarantee has I've
been doing this for over forty years
Wow he used the one who went and told
them this it's not you guys are looking
the wrong thing they never caught they
never caught and he was not the pants I
can guarantee you that and that
the border police like get the [ __ ] out
of here he said you brought me in for a
reason I know you guys have been going
down this this path that my parents and
he goes it's so clear that it's not them
it's I'm funny
and he was like any goes I felt bad for
the pants you just think if your child
is murdered and they blame you yeah she
died of cancer I think and then he's
like in the Arizona suddenly polo shirt
or some [ __ ] Wow well what about that
FBI special though where they showed
that it couldn't have been anyone that
broke in and it was for sure somebody in
the house remember it was on like last
year yeah that was an FBI recreation
yeah they proved that nobody could come
in through the little window I know they
tried to crack where it was broken I'm
gonna fit through there
yeah hmm it was this thing ate your life
yeah no no I think it was the Sun just
like the FBI said yeah you think more
than the expert who we just spoke with
no there was a eight years old yes eight
well they're not saying he staged the
crime scene the FBI guy said mister got
mad hit her with a flashlight some
parents freaked out basement wrote that
fake-ass letter
yeah that could be possible to save your
son yeah that would make sense
damage dad at 49 well that that was a
tragedy all the way around horrible huh
when you see my back ripple and I pull
myself up like a champ like a champ
through 30 times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gif it's a gift
it's a gift